بالفعل فلا يبدو ان اي مفاوضات راويه قد
ترى النور قبل ان تنتهي معركه خرسون التي
لا تعني علامات الانسحاب الروسي منها ان
معركه كيرف لاستعادتها ستكون سهله فبينما
تضغط القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه خرسون احدى
اكبر الجوائز التي حصلت عليها روسيا بعد
اطلاق حربها في فبراير الماضي يريد الجيش
الروسي اللا يستنزف قوته وان يتجنب
انسحابا فوضيا اخر كالذي حصل كيف هناك
اشارات على ان القوات الروسيه تستعد
لمغادره المدينه اذ نقلت سكان والافراد
الى الضفه البعيده لنهر النيترو برو وتخلت
عن بعض نقاط التفتيش حول المدينه ومطارها
كان بوتن دعى الجمعه الى اجزاء المدنيين
من غير سون في اشاره الى قرب اندلاع قتال
عنيف منتظر
[موسيقى]
تنقل
عن مسؤول الغربيه
قالوا ان روسيا ستسعى لارهاق قوات
الاوكرانيه المتقدمه قدر الامكان قبل
الانسحاب اذا لازم الامر تقع خيرسون على
الضفه الغربيه لنهر النيترو والاستراتيجي
مصدر الماء العذب الرئيس باتجاه شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام 2014 وقد تم
عزل الخيصان الى حد كبير عن الضفه الشرقيه
للنهار بسبب ضربات الدقيقه الاوكرانيه ضد
الجسور خطوط الروسيه الاخرى ايضا في
المدينه يتركز الهجوم الرئيس لاوكرانيا في
منطقه خرسوان على التوجه جنوبا نحو مدينه
نوفاكافكا حيث يعمل سد رئيسي على نهر
النيبرو اذا تمكنت اوكرانيا من الاستيلاء
على السد فانها ستؤمن السيطره على خط
امداد رئيسي لخرصان وعلى طريق هروب محتمل
لكنه هناك عوامل عده تعقد تقدم اوكرانيا
لن يجلب فقط الارض المتجمده ولكنه سيعرض
القوات لكشف مواقعها اكثر واكثر مع تساقط
اوراق الشجر المستخدمه للتمويه
كما ان زغرافيا منطقه خيرسون تعتبر معقده
فعلى عكس خارج كيف في الشمال ودم باز في
الشرق فان معظم جنوب اوكرانيا مغطى
بالسهول حيث تترك الحقول المسطحه القوات
مرئيه للقوات الروسيه المتحصنه ما يزيد من
وتيره الاستنزاف ويبطئ من معدل التقدم
يقول قائد فصيل دبابات اوكرانيه من موقعه
على خط المواجهه جنوب شرق نيكولايف ان
الروس يمكنهم تشغيله طائره استطلاع صغيره
ورؤيه مدينه خيرسون كامله عن بعد يقول
ايضا من المستحيل الاختباء
[موسيقى]